a movie called The the interview that
almost started a war you want us to kill
the leader of North Korea
experience yes
baby blame for almost starting a war
part of the movie was shot right here in
our Newsroom little did we know when we
saw Seth Rogen walking around he was
about to set off an international
incident I mean you don't make a movie
about trying to kill like an actual
person who's alive without kind of
expecting or hoping for some sort of uh
rise in in that capacity he called it an
act of war and an act of terrorism which
as a comedian is like what you're
[__] looking for huh
I would have told them do not I'll get
into a pattern in which you're
intimidated
by these kinds of criminal attacks but
that's what's crazy is like it was at
one point the most controversial thing
in the world and now yeah like I'll be
like flipping channels on like a Sunday
afternoon and it's like oh